120 personnes vont se succéder à la
barre au delà de ce procès dont on parle
beaucoup c'est toute la sphère grégory
et ses protagonistes qui vont sans doute
resurgir isabelle spes marcel martin
jean marie villemin vient de passer sa
première nuit en prison
hier encore ils étaient libres ce matin
ses menottes aux poignets qu'il arrive à
8 heures au palais de justice de dijon
c'est la règle aux assises l'accusé doit
comparaître détenu quelques minutes plus
tard une autre arrivée très attendue
celle de marie-ange la veuve de bernard
laroche
elle a vu mourir son époux elle était à
ses côtés le jour du drame
visages fermés ce matin elle ne dira pas
un mot
une chevelure rousse apparaît soudain
dans la com
muriel bolle arrive c'est le témoin clé
de se brosser
elle avait 15 ans à peine à l'époque des
faits c'est elle qui avait accusé son
beau frère bernard d'avoir enlevé
grégory avant de se rétracter mais celle
que tout le monde attendait ne viendra
pas les avocats de christine et jean
marie villemin whissell ils ont le
sourire pour les photos et les petits
mots pour la presse
unie solidaire aux chiens pas un mot en
revanche sur l'absence de christine
villemin témoin au procès de son mari
elle sera entendue vendredi